hi guys
hi hi how are you i am well how are you
good thank you thank you i i'm sure you
hear it a lot
at this point but i absolutely love the
show i also have to admit that as
someone who is not a sports fan at all i
was literally dragged into watching the
show
because i was convinced and i fell in
love with it it just keeps getting
better i love the episodes i've seen
this season
so thank you great
thank you so much christina i'm really
glad you like the season two stuff
you've seen that's cool
i'm curious is does the optimism of this
show
rub off on any of the cynicism you might
have
in your own life is it just does it
become infectious
yes undeniably a huge yes
[Laughter]
yeah i mean it was apparent when we were
making season one that it was affecting
us
and becoming a part of our everyday life
in ways that you
i don't know weren't even aware that it
wasn't there you know what i mean and
then you're suddenly like wow
i've been kind of
person to everybody including myself
which that was a kind of whoa
moment for me um yeah it was definitely
contagious
i think everyone wants to be better
because of
making ted lasse and the way we make it
we we often
sometimes we're making a decision and it
is it is almost literally like what
would said last i do and we're like well
the best way of doing it is this and
that's how we would then make that thing
yeah i mean anybody i know that tells me
they're having a bad day or a bad week
my first response is always have you
watched ted lasso yet because you might
want to try that
that's fine man you feel better
that's great i still can't get over
bill lawrence suggesting that you play
higgins i mean that seems crazy
especially now that we've seen the show
so did you ever seriously actually
consider
taking that role no i thought it to
be to be fair to bill lawrence
that was at the point where higgins
hadn't been fully formulated as a
character
i think that bill was like you know you
could play the bumbling english guy
character i think was sort of it but the
truth is when we saw
jeremy swift's casting tape he
got the part of higgins before he'd
finished introducing himself
on that tape he literally was like hello
i'm jeremy swift did a funny noise and
we were like that's higgins
we didn't even have to see the scenes so
i never really took it seriously that i
was an option for higgins
but i think bill was just trying to um
tricked me into thinking i could get a
part in this show
little did he know
you know keely really embraces her
ambition this season which is
nice to see i mean she's been doing that
so
what do you enjoy about getting to play
that how empowering does that feel to
get to play someone who is
embracing their ambition
uh it's so great because she does it
with such
conviction and such a genuine heart and
she's like
there's almost like a childlike quality
about it because she's had the
encouragement of this woman
rebecca who's played by obviously the
extraordinary hannah waddingham
who in my real life has completely
blown my mind and keeley
her mind is blown by rebecca too and
their friendship and the encouragement
that she's been given by this woman that
she looks up to
and thinks is
truly an inspiration and uh
so then to kind of have that fire behind
you
and also to be excited about
this new opportunity like it feels like
she's got the support around her to go
and get it and at the same time yeah
she's excited and she's like
hungry for it but at the same time
because there's this slightly childlike
quality about her
she's not afraid to try things with
all of her because if it goes wrong
she'll figure that out later she
has a very lovely boyfriend that i think
will help pick up the pieces if she
really fell flat on her face
i love that these two are not only
intimate with each other but they're not
afraid to actually have a conversation
about it and about what works for them
is it refreshing to play and explore a
relationship dynamic where the two
people
in it actually care enough about having
those conversations and talking about
what actually makes them happy
definitely yes
[Laughter]
yeah uh next question no yes
it's a real uh look i i i cannot
i think it's it's almost probably boring
to hear how much i love doing scenes
with you know
and uh and getting to play this
relationship is
uh it was really magic like
i love it and um i do and i think
that's why it works we're very invested
you jump i jump babe
oh but roy obviously swears a lot
but it almost seems kind of like a term
of endearment
for him because thank you you get it
christina he's passionate whenever he's
talking about something that he's
swearing more about so does that feel
like
a fair assessment of his relationship
with swearing is it
is it when he's more passionate about
something
roy's relationship with swearing is the
same as my relationship with swearing
it's uh it it comes from it comes from
love
uh there's there's ways of swearing yeah
it's it
uh it's how he expresses uh
all his love and emotions and i think uh
something i think that is kind of
amazing about said lasso which
you know we didn't know if it would work
but i think it's funny when you think
about it that it's quite
unique in that it seems to be from the
responses we're getting
it's a show that people watch with their
families like i think there's an element
of it that feels like a very warm family
show
but it's got a [ __ ] ton of swearing in
it and a [ __ ] ton of sex stuff in it
it's a real mix of stuff that
i'm surprised how many people go yeah i
watch it with my kids and i'm like great
i don't see why not other than the
relentless [ __ ] swearing and
sex and dark stuff but yeah i love it
jason has talked about a very clear
three-season arc for this show
and that the show is always meant to be
three seasons so
if that is ultimately the case and you
only have one season left has that
reality actually
set in
no i think we're all into
we're all in denial of it i think if it
was up to
us it would run for 30 seasons and we'd
never stop
doing this because i think we love
making it so much
but uh i do know that
the the i can't really say i know the
i know the the concept of the three
season plan
at least in period
the relationship between kelly and
rebecca and it is such a great part of
the show
what is the most valuable thing you
think rebecca has taught keely
and and what do you think is the most
valuable thing kaylee can stop rebecca
i think um rebecca is the first woman
in kelly's life to really really say
a good little brain on you girl go forth
and use it
because you could be doing
spl stuff and you really understand
people and understand how to make people
feel good about themselves
and you're really savvy and and
you're more than just famous for being
almost famous
you know and i really think that rebecca
is the first woman to do that for keely
and um
i think that kiwi
shows rebecca that she
just loves her and that rebecca
even when she's feeling fragile or
you know uncomfortable in her skin
and um alone
and maybe even a little fearful that
she's perfect that way and that she
needs to
own each moment because she's ex an
extraordinary creature
is there an aspect for each of you in
your characters that you wish you had
i wish i had as much hair as keeley
i wish i had as much chest hair as roy
but you know we have to put that wig on
it
mine's not i would also not mind
or cup sizes up too that'd be great but
no i mean
i love she's become a part of my life i
love her
so much i love her so much and
i feel like i'm a more
i don't know multi-colored person
for having to get to for getting to play
her
as for roy i love playing roy and i wish
i had less of a i mean i'm working on it
i wish i had less of a care of what
people thought of me
so that i could be more like roy
you just have to growl at them so then
they they will leave you alone
okay that's good advice christina
well thank you guys so much i love the
show i love both of you your characters
are fantastic so thank you
thank you very much because you're
really nice to me thank you thank you